[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
March 21st I'm Erin Delmore for the Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
some apprenticeships are harder to get
into than an ivy league university more
and more students are choosing them over
traditional four-year colleges I'm Erin
Delmore and joining me is Wall Street
Journal reporter Doug Belkin Doug thank
you for being with us thanks very much
for the invitation so Doug tell me more
about these apprenticeship programs how
do they work mostly students will take
classes often in community college but
not always sometimes in a four-year
college and they'll be working at the
same time and they'll have a mentor at
work so they'll be learning a trade
traditionally the trade's been in
construction or something blue collar
but more and more we're seeing these pop
up in white collar industries and
insurance and Banking and I.T and so
they're going to school on the
one-handed learning the theory about how
an industry works and then second half
of the week they're in an office
building or at a construction site and
they're actually performing what they're
learning and they're getting paid for it
okay so you're saying that we're seeing
these apprenticeship models move into
more of a white collar space Insurance
banking I.T where else are we seeing
them which Industries and which parts of
the country they really spread all over
then what's interesting about this
phenomena is that it's very organic it's
being driven in high schools it's being
driven from corporations it's being
driven within the trades and the
government is also behind some of it so
it's kind of popping up everywhere
because the need to get more skilled
workers into the labor market is intense
and there's just a skills mismatch which
is prompting people to think a little
bit more creatively about how to do this
and do it quickly
should we take all of this as a sign
that traditional four-year colleges are
losing a bit of their appeal yet they're
facing headwinds and they have been for
a number of years probably since the
Great Recession the cost of a University
degree continues to outstrip earnings
and more importantly I think the risk of
going into debt for a degree that may or
may not pay off and that you may or may
not get only about 60 percent of kids
who start a four-year degree graduate in
six years that means that you could be
laying out a hundred two hundred
thousand dollars for a degree that lands
you a job that you don't need a degree
for and that's scaring a lot of people
and it's prompting them to reevaluate
their options you know it's not lost to
me that these young workers entering the
Workforce Now spent a bulk of their high
school years during the pandemic
learning remotely I'm wondering if that
turned them off to the idea of investing
more in in-person education right it
makes a lot of sense the there's been a
great disengagement from classrooms kids
are not plugged in the way they used to
we're seeing it in terms of testing and
what students know when they graduate
high school is significantly less than
what they did before the Pandemic part
of that's just because kids are
disengaged and so just want to spend
another few years in school is a bit of
a stretch now for this cohort of kids
what's Wild to me is that by your
reporting we're seeing acceptance rates
that rival Ivy League schools for these
apprenticeships aren't we yes one of the
programs got 1500 applications this year
for 100 spots so that's like a 6.6
percent acceptance rate which is about
the same as Cornell University there's
something you're tapping on that's at
play in The Wider job market here
employers are struggling to find and
retain Talent it's a tight labor market
and it sounds like with this model they
can put an attractive offer on the table
some paid work some paid school and they
can reach more people by dropping out
degree requirements so tell me more
about how the employers you spoke with
are seeing these apprenticeship
opportunities from the perspective of
the corporations this this can be a
really good model because they get
trained smart young kids in the door at
a relatively low price they don't have
to hire adults who are going to ask them
for much more money
so it's a good source of kind of cheap
labor for a lot of these industries and
because the students come in they build
relationships there their retention rate
at least in the early going
is much stronger than other folks so it
works from the perspective of the
corporations at least that's what it
looks like right now so I think that's
another reason why we're more likely to
see these continue to grow I'm curious
whether this serves workers long term
though what do we know about their
career trajectories after the
apprenticeship is over so this is the
argument against apprenticeships and the
idea is that if you go to college and
you learn to think critically and
broadly and to synthesize information
then you're essentially able to learn
how to learn and you're more adaptable
going forward if you get a narrow
education in a with a less broad skill
set and that skill is no longer deemed
important or valuable in the marketplace
you could be a bit out of luck so
there's some research looking at
Apprentice programs internationally that
shows that workers in their 40s and 50s
begin to sort of fade out if they don't
reskill then they struggle and a lot of
them leave the labor market and that's
the risk that
The Apprentice programs take the counter
argument to that is that we're entering
a period now where it's never going to
be enough to stop learning at 21 or 22
years old because the labor market
because technology is moving so quickly
because AI is breathing down everybody's
neck everybody's going to have to
continue to reskill all the time and so
whether you start as an apprentice or a
college graduate you're going to have to
keep learning and so as long as you
accept that it's not a bad way to start
Doug you spoke to a few people most of
them young about choosing
apprenticeships over four-year colleges
so what do our listeners need to know
about making that calculation themselves
so there's a financial calculation in
the psychological calculation I think
that are in play and part of this bumps
up against class
if you come from a family or from a
community where college is expected it's
very hard to say I'm not going to go to
college because that for two generations
has been the pathway towards success
this is changing I think more in the
working classes in the lower middle
classes where colleges become such a
risk that an apprenticeship looks much
more interesting but it's sort of
creeping up the class ladder I think is
what's happening and one of the
professors I spoke to said the prestige
shift will happen when apprentices begin
to occupy the c-suite and that's
happening in Europe because there's a
vocational model in Europe now and you
can do very well going this way so in a
few years there's going to be kids who
started out as apprentices continue
their education rose up through the
ranks and are running these companies
and then young people are going to see
that the CEO is an apprentice and so if
it worked for him or her it can work for
them and I think that will begin to
shift the thinking in the country around
this that was reporter Doug Belkin Doug
thanks for being here thanks very much
for having me and that's your money
briefing I'm Erin Delmore for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]